guy cormier président et chef de la
direction de desjardins est avec nous ce
qu'on me bonsoir bonsoir c'est une
journée triste pour desjardins la 7
journée triste pour desjardins je suis
pour quelqu'un qui travaille comme moi
depuis 27 ans chez desjardins là je me
sens trahi je c'est inacceptable ce qui
se passe comment un seul employé ont pu
vendre parce qu'on présume qu'ils
vendaient n'est ce pas en puis vendent
autant d'informations sur autant de
membres on parle de près de 3 millions
de membres quand même et que je peux pas
présumer ce qu'a fait cet employé le
premièrement je vais laisser je vais
laisser les enquêtes policières du
service de police de laval poursuivre
son enquête
par contre pour ce qui est des
procédures internes à desjardins je vous
rassure des mécanismes de sécurité sont
existants et plusieurs mécanismes de
sécurité ici ce qu'on fait face c'est un
employé malveillants qui a usé d'un
stratagème deux pour être capables
d'obtenir de l'information et pouvoir la
sortir de desjardins
qu'est-ce qu'il envoyait à ses clients
non numéro d'assurance sociale date de
naissance au delà de la mer ils
envoyaient assez d'informations pour que
des bandits plus forger une identité
essentiellement on sait pas on parle des
noms de famille des prénoms des adresses
des dates de naissance des numéros
d'assurance sociale et parfois leur
certaines informations sur la détention
jld et des jardins je tiens très très
clair ici là il n'y a pas de numéro il
n'y a pas de nip de numéro
d'identification personnel il ya pas de
code d'accès il n'y a pas de questions
d'authentification donc ça de ceux des
mesures de sécurité qui nous rassure
donc il ya personne avec ses
informations le qui ne sont pas sortir
des jardins les gens ont peu accès à
l'information dans les comptes comme
c'est une chose d'avoir des informations
c'est une autre chose de pouvoir accéder
aux comptes hélas cette information lors
ne pas sortir des jardins et y envoyer
ses acquis je vous dirais que on n'a pas
cette information est honnêtement elle
est le site entier mais des dépôts liste
des policiers de laval l'actuel ok mais
faisait pas ça pour le fun là il faisait
ça pour de l'argent
imagine écoutez moi je veux pas spéculer
sur cette employée là moi je peux vous
parler de ses employées lorsqu'il
faisait chez desjardins et faisait des
choses qui étaient illégales et il a
sorti l'information desjardins
maintenant où elle est rendue cette
information là est ce que ce qu'il en a
fait lui personnellement ça fait partie
d'une enquête policière alors qu'ils
étaient en cours alors je réponds je
veux pas nourrir cette enquête club très
bien mais pour les trois millions de
membres touchés le danger encore une
fois c'est confort junior dit et par
exemple moi le chemin des jardins par
exemple un bon exemple on peut prendre
mon nom et avec toutes les informations
que les gens obtenu ils peuvent se
forger mon identité puis à les faire
beaucoup de choses
un faux passeport etc etc etc moi j'ai
pas un spécialiste du pain spécialisée
dans la fraude avec les renseignements
personnels
mais c'est pour ça qu'on a pris la
décision chez desjardins d'offrir au
monde qui lui vaudront une couverture
avec equifax qui était une couverture
une surveillance d'identité donc les
gens vont en revanche equifax les gens
vont être capables de voir s'il ya des
transactions ou des activités douteuses
sur des comptes vont être capables
d'envoyer des alertes à nos membres
ils vont aussi être capable d'offrir une
assurance vol d'identité et on va on va
être en mesure avec cette assurance le
couvert par desjardins jusqu'à 50000
dollars de pouvoir couvrir si je deviens
s'il advenait des situations comme vous
expliquer et ça comment j'allais
communiqué cette information là tous les
membres touchés qui pourront être morte
des facs gratuitement pour un an
ben écoutez premièrement on a fait une
conférence de presse aujourd'hui pour
nous c'est important d'être transparent
et de communiquer publiquement
deuxièmement de cette semaine on a
entrepris les démarches pour transmettre
dès la personnaliser à tous nos membres
qui va se faire leur au cours des
prochains jours dans une semaine une
semaine et demie les gens vont savoir
cette lettre là ils vont avoir un code
d'accès ils vont activer ce code d'accès
leur est automatiquement ils vont être
sur cette couverture là d'equifax tous
souhaitent offrir des jardins là je
tiens à le dire et aussi les gens vont
avoir sur ce pour ce qu'il faut faire
sur nos plates formes électroniques vont
recevoir un message courriel dans les
prochaines heures pour les aviser que le
leur dossier a fait l'objet de cette
fuite d'informations là et vont recevoir
une lettre sous peu et comme je le dis
les gens peuvent à pied dans nos centres
contact clientèle peuvent à leur guise
nos gens sont prêts à répondre là dessus
combien de temps cet homme là a fait ça
cette information mais comme je vous dis
a fait partie de l' enquête criminelle
donc je peux pas je peux pas aller dans
les détails ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que nous quand on a été informé
par le corps policier de laval vendredi
dernier le 14 juin d'informations très
précises
ça nous a pris à peu près une journée ou
deux le décrypter les données
immédiatement on a rehaussé
on a mis de l'avant des mesures
additionnelles de sécurité surtout les
quantités en dire leur poids juste les
comptes des deux points 9 million man
tous les membres de desjardins
depuis les dernières semaines ont vu des
mesures additionnelles de sécurité sur
l'eau sur les comptes est aujourd'hui
l'élève le processus débute que deux
courts question en terminant est-ce que
vous avez vu pendant qu'ils agissaient
une montée des fraudes envers les
membres
c'est une question intéressante au cours
des derniers mois nous n'avons pas vu
aucune cause de fraudes plus grande ce
que ce qu'on a pu voir en 2018 donc ce
qu'on se dit c'est que nos mécanismes de
sécurité la vue qui au fond ils n'ont
pas les nippes et on peut les processus
d'authentification à lyon pas les
questions
y'a pas de hausse de fraude chez
desjardins au cours des derniers mois et
est ce que une personne qui travaille
chez desjardins aujourd'hui est encore
capable d'envoyer à x y z art monde
interlope importe à qui des informations
personnelles
qu'est-ce que vous avez changé
concrètement pour mettre fin à cette
possibilité là bas écouter premièrement
je vous rassure ce stratagème là il a
été clairement identifié on a mis les
mesures en place pour désactiver
complètement ce qui ce qui a fait donc
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une autre
employée qui est capable de faire la
même chose que cet individu leur aux
fesses à s'exprimer soit vous détailler
pour ce qui est maintenant de vous
détailler les procédures qu'on a fait
mais je pourrais comprendre que le off
on parle de procédures de sécurité et je
veux pas les exprimer publiquement non
plus très bien guy cormier
on va en reparler certainement plus d'un
chef la direction des jardins merci nous
avons parlé percée